[Musik]
immer mehr Viertklässler haben Probleme
mit dem schreiben lesen und rechnen
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
verbreitet ungebrochen corona-panik und
die deutschen Supermärkte schließen
früher um Strom zu sparen viel Zündstoff
heute Abend bei viertel nach acht meine
Gäste Kinderarzt und anti-actum
atomaktivist Alex Rosen sein Thema heute
abend stoppt die Atommeiler atomkraft
ist gefährlich bildpolitikchef Jan
Schäfer er spricht heute über den
bildungsrückstand der die
Wirtschaftsleistung des ganzen Landes
sinken lassen könnte reiner Hand ist
Wirtschaftsjournalist Kolumnist und
ehemaliger Leiter Wirtschafts- und
finanzredaktion der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung er
vergleicht heute Abend die Situation im
Jahr 1972 mit heute wo liegen die
Parallelen und hat die Politik die
Inflation damals besser bekämpft ich
muss gestehen ich bin sehr gespannt auf
diesen Diskurs auch mit von der Partie
Stefan kurz als Ökonom und Vizepräsident
des Kieler Instituts für Weltwirtschaft
er sagt die Regierung subventioniert mit
dem gasdeckel ins Nichts schön dass Sie
alle da ich würde sagen geballte
Wirtschaftsexperte sitzt heute Abend
hier am Tisch ein fast ohne Boden ist
auch die corona-politik Impfstoffe
maskentest all das geht in die
Milliarden aber die schlimmste Kronach
Folge ist für mich persönlich der
Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der Politik und
anstatt diesen aufzuarbeiten geht es
auch schon wieder los
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
verbreitet ungebrochene corona-panik
hören wir doch mal rein
ist jetzt wirklich an der Zeit die
Fallzahlen steigen die Zahl der
Todesfälle mit und an Corona steigt die
Intensivstationen
belegen sich zunehmend und sind in
einigen Bereichen bereits vor der
Überlastung wir haben darüber hinaus
keinen Grund anzunehmen dass die Welle
die wir jetzt vor uns haben dass sie
sich selbst
begrenzt das heißt es wird einfach immer
so weitergehen und die Frage ist
zumindest für die nächsten Wochen oder
so weitergehen aber das vielleicht mal
etwas langsamer steigen dann wieder
schneller steigen dann wieder etwas
langsamer steigen aber die Richtung in
die wir unterwegs sind ist keine gute
und wir wissen aus der Pandemie je
früher man die Bremse tritt
desto besser ist es weil wir müssen
lange auf der Bremse bleiben falls Sie
jetzt glauben dass es bestimmt ein
Einspieler der zwei Jahre her ist nein
das war erst vor wenigen Tagen in der
Bundespressekonferenz und ich frage mich
wirklich langsam was das eigentlich noch
soll also zum Beispiel Joe Biden der
amerikanische Präsident hat schon für
beendet erklärt aber Karl Lauterbach
macht immer weiter und damit nicht genug
erwirbt auch für das impfenumverdrossen
weiter 33 Millionen Euro kostet die
Impfkampagne ich schütze mich aber die
Wahrheit ist doch wer glaubt ihm denn
jetzt noch welche Impfung und wie viele
angebracht sind ich bin der Überzeugung
dass es allerhöchste Zeit für eine
ehrliche impfkommunikation ist denn das
Versprechen dass die corona-impfung
Schutz vor Ansteckung bietet ist nie
eingetreten laut der Zeitung Welt gab es
auch vor Zulassung nie Studien die
dieses Versprechen schützen schützen die
zwei g-regelung die hingegen wurde also
ohne jegliche Grundlage eingeführt und
ich bin der absolut Überzeugung dass wir
mehr Glaubwürdigkeit in der Politik
brauchen ich habe hier heute Abend mit
Herr Rosen einen Kinderarzt sitzen und
da interessiert mich natürlich wie sie
das mit der Glaubwürdigkeit vor allem in
Bezug auf die Kinder sehen also vor
allem im Bezug auf die Kinder ist ja die
corona-pandemie von Anfang an nicht das
schreckensgespenst gewesen was es für
ältere Leute Erwachsene mit chronischen
Erkrankungen bietet insofern waren wir
als Kinderärzte da tatsächlich nicht an
der vordersten Front bei dieser Pandemie
Gott sei Dank muss man sagen ich sehe
das ein bisschen anders was die
Glaubwürdigkeit angeht ich glaube wir
haben es in dieser Pandemie oft die
Situation gesehen dass wir eine Art
trial and era machen unsere Gesellschaft
hat zumindest in den letzten Jahrzehnten
mit so einer Herausforderung nicht zu
tun gehabt und wir waren das muss man
ganz ehrlich sagen auch als
Gesundheitswesen nicht darauf
vorbereitet und viele der Entscheidung
die getroffen wurden mögen im Nachhinein
als unzureichend falsch oder auch
verunsichernd wirken aber in der
Situation kann ich durchaus verstehen
dass sie getroffen wurden wir sind ganz
gut durch die panemie gekommen sehen uns
ein konkretes Beispiel nehmen wir mal
die 2g-regelung vom letzten Winter wo
der Menschen die hinfahren
ausgeschlossen wurden von der sozialen
Teilhabe sehen Sie das auch als Trial
and Error was man hinnehmen muss ich
sehe es als Trial ob man es hinnehmen
ganz klar sagen die corona-pandemie ist
ein globales Problem und wir hatten
keinen anderen Virus als die anderen
Länder das wurde bei uns nicht
eingeführt genau es gab Länder die noch
viel extremer als wir darauf reagiert
haben Spanien Italien China und es gab
Länder die weniger extrem reagiert haben
und jetzt im Nachhinein kann man sehen
manche Länder sind mit ihrem Kurs besser
gefahren als wir und andere nicht was
meinen Sie hier mit extremer weil von
der Länge der Maßnahmen her war zum
Beispiel Spanien nicht länger als
Deutschland in Spanien durften die
Kinder monatelang das Haus nicht
verlassen auch in Italien die Familien
waren eingesperrt da hatten wir noch
einen einen eine große Menge an
Freiheiten ich will gar nicht sagen dass
alle Maßnahmen richtig waren ich muss
nur sagen als jemand der im
Gesundheitswesen arbeitet der an der
Impfkampagne beteiligt war der täglich
Aufklärungsgespräche geführt hat mit
Menschen mit Corona die Angst hatten vor
Corona die Angst hatten vor der Impfung
das Problem der Glaubwürdigkeit kann ich
akzeptieren ich glaube aber das ist
insgesamt ein Problem war dass wir alle
in der Situation die Fakten nicht hatten
das kann man auch kritisieren warum
hatten wir die Fakten nicht warum wurde
nicht mehr investiert in bessere
Statistik und mehr Forschung zum
Beispiel dass man gemerkt hat dass man
sich nach der Impfung angesteckt hat
also da muss ich nur meinen
Freundeskreis gucken dass man nach der
zweiten Impfung sehr ersichtlich als
plötzlich der halbe Freundeskreis krank
war alle geimpft aber nicht schlimm das
muss man schon sagen also da scheint die
Impfung dann doch was gelindert zu haben
sie haben völlig recht man hat uns
versprochen einmal geimpft und du
brauchst keine Angst mehr haben das
Versprechen ist nicht angetreten aber
andererseits sind die schweren Verläufe
wie können Mediziner die sind doch
deutlich zurückgegangen weil sich das
Virus verändert hat aber bei uns doch
das Immunsystem eine andere Form von
Resilienz hatte aber Virus hat sich auch
verändert und das Virus hat sich eben
auch verändert und das hat uns die
Impfung die Erfolge der Impfkampagne
hauptsächlich verhagelt wir haben gegen
einen Virus geimpft und plötzlich war
ein anderer Serotyp da und dann kam die
durchbruchinfekt das hat hätte man sehen
können dass das passieren kann aber die
Hoffnung war natürlich dass mit dieser
Impfung tatsächlich mehr Freiheiten
kommen die Realität sah tatsächlich
anders aus darf ich ihn mal ein ganz
konkretes Beispiel für meinen
Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust in die
Gesundheit also in den
Gesundheitsminister aber auch in die
Regierung aufzeigen die Empfehlungen für
die corona-impfung waren für meinen
60-Jährigen Vater und für mich als
30-jährige Frau damals noch 29 komplett
identisch das hat mich sehr gewundert
von Anfang an welchem Zeitpunkt weil es
war ja lange
also uns beiden komplett gleich
empfohlen das hatte ich mich damals sehr
sehr stark gewundert ob das nicht schon
ein Unterschied macht wie alt man ist
wie groß man ist also es gab ja gar
keine Differenzierung am Anfang in der
Impfkampagne sehe ich anders weil die
ständige Impfung hat natürlich die alten
Leute die Menschen über 60 das kann man
sagen 59 nicht aber die Menschen über 60
priorisiert wir haben ja alle warten
müssen gut ich im Gesundheitswesen nicht
ich war in der Notaufnahme damals tätig
da habe ich als allererste die Impfung
bekommen aber viele von meinen Bekannten
in meinem Alter
nicht von der Menge also die dritte
Booster Impfung zum Beispiel also ich
habe mich nicht wirklich abgeholt
gefühlt aber das hat mit dem Immunsystem
zu tun eine 2+1 Impfung ist ja das was
wir bei Tetanus und bei vielen anderen
Impfungen auch machen das Immunsystem
funktioniert einfach so dass man zwei
Erinnerungen braucht bei den meisten
Viren um anständig geschützt zu sein ich
kann ich kann sie total verstehen ich
glaube dass viele Leute
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem sehen ich will
nur da argumentieren dass es nicht immer
nur schlechte Politik war sondern
sicherlich auch eine sehr
unübersichtliche und sich ständig
wandelnde Lage ich würde sagen das
größte Problem in der Kommunikation beim
Umgang mit der Pandemie war dass wir den
Eindruck erweckt hatten oder das einige
den Eindruck erweckt hatten Wissenschaft
könnte jetzt Politik ersetzen und das
kann sie eben nicht denn wir haben es
hier mit allen mit vielen Zielen zu tun
die Politik immer gegeneinander
ausbalancieren muss das können
ökonomische
Faktoren sein natürlich
gesundheitsfaktoren aber auch innerhalb
der Gesundheitsziele unterschiedliche
Ziele die gegeneinander stehen
psychologische Schäden die eintreten
wenn wir Menschen zu Hause lassen und
vieles mehr und es wurde immer der
Eindruck erweckt es gäbe den Königsweg
oder den richtigen Weg den gibt die
Wissenschaft vor und darüber werden
keine Debatte mehr möglich aber
der Unterschied sehen genau
gegeneinander abzuwägen und es gibt
keine Wissenschaft der Welt die der
Politik diese Aufgabe abnehmen kann mich
und das würde ich da knüpfig so ein
bisschen anders was du am Anfang glaube
ich gesagt hast Nina stört eigentlich
dass auch der Bundesgesundheitsminister
so tut als wenn wir uns wirklich so kann
man die Worte so ein bisschen deuten
noch ganz am Anfang dieser Pandemie
eigentlich befinden also wir sind
vielleicht im Sommer 2020 es gibt noch
keinen Impfstoff und wir wissen auch
noch gar nicht welche Masken wir
eigentlich tragen sollen und den
Eindruck hat man und wenn man in unsere
Gesellschaft reinhorcht ob es jetzt
Schulen sind ob es Behörden sind ob es
auch
Beschäftigte in verschiedenen Firmen
sind hat man doch häufig oder mein
Eindruck ist zumindest das ist eine neue
angstkultur gibt die eigentlich dort
aufhört wo wir im Frühjahr 2020 gewesen
sind also die so tut als wenn es die
ganzen Impfungen sie haben das ja gerade
auch gesagt nie gegeben hat sie haben
auch angesprochen dass man mit Impfungen
natürlich in der meisten Fällen gar
nicht so stark dann mehr erkrankte oder
die Symptome gar nicht so stark waren
und das macht ein riesen Unterschied für
die
Berechtigung für politische Eingriffe
gibt es jetzt die fremdschutzaspekte
oder nicht genau und die Herausforderung
glaube die ist die ganz entscheidende
gerade auch mit Blick auf die Schulen
aus diesem angstmodus herauszukommen der
Bundesgesundheitsminister setzt sich hin
und sagt ja er spricht von Menschen die
mit und an Corona erkranken er weiß gar
nicht genau wie eigentlich die
Zusammensetzung ist sind es 90% mit
Corona und nur noch 10% an Corona oder
sind 95 zu fünf dass diese Zahlen liegen
der Bundesregierung zumindestens gesagt
das ist ja nur ein Ausschnitt eines
spielt gar keine Rolle ob mit oder eine
ganz genau
keine Rolle weil wenn derjenige dann
vielleicht nicht auch noch Corona
bekommen hätte trotz seiner Herzschwäche
wäre er nicht verstorben so erklärt
folgendem Grund spielt es in einem
Aspekt keine Rolle nämlich für den
Ausfall im Arbeitsmarkt ob jemand jetzt
wegen eines Verkehrsunfalls eine ins
Krankenhaus kommt und auf Corona positiv
getestet wird oder aufgrund einer
Atemwegsinfektion er wird positiver
Corona getestet und fällt für fünf bis
zehn Tage für den Arbeitsmarkt aus oder
die Schüler für den Schulen und das ist
eigentlich die große
furchtbarbefälle Sterbefall
wenn ich mit einem gebrochenen Bein
eingeliefert werde ins Krankenhaus und
zufällig festgestellt wird ich bin auch
noch an corona-erkrankt dann wäre ich
wegen des gebrochenen Beines ausgefallen
in fünf Tage für die Arbeit aus weil
zusätzliches gebrochen
was ich sagen will ist die große Furcht
ist dass diesen Winter
aufgrund von so vielen coronafällen wir
gesellschaftlich runterfahren müssen
weil keine Taxifahrer mehr da sind wir
mit den Corona Fällen anders
müsste neu diskutieren zum Beispiel die
Tumorerkrankungen es wurden noch nie so
schwere tumorfälle in so einer
Häufigkeit wie jetzt weil die Menschen
nicht mehr zu Vorsorge gegangen sind
riesen Problem und das ist natürlich
auch das Problem bei Kindern auch wenn
ich deswegen permanent erzähle das
schlimmste was passieren kann ist eine
corona-erkrankung und so tut es der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ja auch noch
dann muss ich mich nicht wundern wenn
der Ruf als Echo zurückkommt und zwar in
Folgen der Gestalt das ganz ganz viele
Menschen panische Angst davor haben sich
wieder anzustecken und dann auch wenn
Sie den Coronavirus wieder haben oder
das erste Mal haben auch nicht zur
Arbeit gehen und und das Gefühl haben oh
Gott ich bin quasi Aussätziger ich muss
fünf bis zehn Tage zu Hause bleiben ob
ich Symptome habe oder nicht spielt
keine Rolle also der Umgang mit dem
Virus der ist eigentlich der gleiche wie
schon weiter diese panische Angst ist ja
nicht mehr da sage ich und die ist an
Schulen sowas von verbreitet die das ist
das ist das glauben sie gar nicht das
ist der herrscht panische Angst panische
Angst davor da wird jetzt schon darüber
genießen weiter zum Teil als der
Berliner Senat und der ist bei diesen
ganzen Ding immer schon ziemlich weit
gewesen es gibt ja noch eine andere
Angst die wir haben in der Gesellschaft
und das ist die Energiekrise Christian
Lindner hat gesagt wir befinden uns in
einem energiekrieg und da haben wir
heute Herr Rosen hier der seine These
mitgebracht hat zu den Atomkraftwerken
ja also die Atomkraftwerke über den
Jahres Jahre endlich hinaus zu betreiben
das ist ein bisschen so als würde man
jetzt sich denken ich mache eine Fahrt
mit meiner mit der Bahnfahrt schön in
Urlaub ach auf den letzten Drücker sage
ich doch nämlich noch das Auto hat zwar
keinen TÜV war vor 13 Jahren das letzte
Mal zur Inspektion will auch keiner
versichern und der Motor hat Risse aber
ich mache es trotzdem fahr auf der
Autobahn drei Monate lang mit 180 das
Risiko das dadurch entsteht
das tragen wir alle und das ist das
Problem was wir jetzt sehen als Anti
akw-bewegung als atomkritische
Medizinerinnen und Mediziner das von
einigen Seiten eine Lösung für die
Energiekrise versprochen wird eine
einfache Lösung vermeintlich einfach die
die gesundheitlichen die ökologischen
und auch die Sicherheitsrisiken
eigentlich außen vor lässt und einfacher
erscheint als sie tatsächlich ist
bedenkt man die Probleme die Isaac Isa 2
und Neckarwestheim 2 jetzt noch haben
angesichts der ventilschäden in Isa und
angesichts der rissigen Rohre in
Neckarwestheim also da ist das letzte
Wort noch nicht gesprochen ob das so
einfach geht die weiter betreiben zu
lassen oder ob doch Reparaturen dem
Ganzen eine Schippe schlagen
Herren sehen Sie das auch so dass es
gefährlich ist es wie es weiterlaufen
lassen ich sehe das anders
ökonomisch würde man erst einmal sagen
in einer so schweren Krise wie diese
Energiekrise geht es darum dass Angebot
auszuweiten um sich von nicht weiter von
diesem Gaspreis abhängig zu machen und
Angebot erweitern heißt alles was wir
ein Energiequellen haben nutzen und dazu
gehört die Atomenergie auch deswegen
weil es eine heimische Energie ist da
müssen wir nicht extra in den vorderen
Orient pilgern zu starten die nicht
minder autoritär sind wie Russland oder
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
aggressiv sind sondern wir haben eine
eigene Energieform sie ist ökologisch
klimäßig das sauberste was mir haben und
sie ist aber auch am wenigsten riskant
das ist der Punkt wo ich ihn am meisten
widersprechen würde ich habe mir heute
weil ich wusste dass sie kommen
angeschaut Max rosa ist ein Mensch in
Oxford aber world in data heißt das der
verl gleiche Statistiken hat und er hat
aufgemacht eine Reihenfolge der hört
sich ein bisschen zynisch an der
Todesfälle pro Terra
wattstunde und da steht ganz oben die
Kohle als nächstes kommt das Öl dann
kommt das natural gas dann kommt sogar
der Wind und dann erst kommt also bei
der Kohle sind wir 25 Todesfälle auf
diese terrarwattstunde und beim Atom
sind es
0,03 und er hat große Zahlen sowohl für
Tschernobyl wie auch für Fukushima ein
also man kann ihn nicht vorwerfen dass
er an der Stelle minimiert hat sondern
er hat das Risiko dieser beiden aber
mehr haben wir gar nicht im Vergleich zu
viel also man muss auch da abwägen alles
ist riskant im Leben aber relativ ist
die Atomenergie die am wenigsten wissen
haben wir abgewogen als Gesellschaft
zweimal in den letzten 20 Jahren haben
wir einen breiten gesellschaftlichen
Konsens was wir in Deutschland
ein Sonderweg machen und sie sagen wir
müssen nicht in vorigen Orient der Uran
der benutzt wird das kommt natürlich aus
dem Niger das kommt aus Kasachstan also
wir müssen natürlich das Importieren das
ist keine heimische wir produzieren kein
Uran mehr seit 1990 und man muss einfach
sagen dass die Atomkraftwerke jetzt die
Gaskrise lösen das stimmt einfach nicht
wir haben keinen Strom Mengenproblem wir
haben ein netzstabilitätsproblem im
nächsten Jahr
Preisproblem haben wir aber Marit order
nennen dass wir wir haben einen so
teuren Strompreis weil wir Gas
verstromen müssen und das könnten wir
zurückfahren
die teuerste Stromproduktion die es
überhaupt nur gibt aber was geht das ist
wirklich ein bunter Strauß an Argumenten
das finde ich toll weil es eigentlich
alles miteinander vermischt es gibt kein
Argument was
möchte ich sagen vorsichtig ausgedrückt
dann vielleicht doch lustig genug ist um
genannt zu werden also ihr Beispiel mit
dem TÜV und dem Auto das ist ja nun
wirklich das Falscheste was man machen
kann denn der TÜV SÜD hat ja erst
kürzlich bestätigt dass es überhaupt
kein Problem ist diese Kernkraftwerke
länger laufen zu lassen und er hat noch
mal auch bestätigt dass es bei den
Kernkraftwerken die es hier in
Deutschland geht sich um die sichersten
Handel selbst die die schon abgeschaltet
wurden Ende 21 die wir auf der Welt
haben alle zehn Jahre also muss eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung stattfinden aber
fand 2009
das glauben sie sollte 2019 wieder
stattfinden ist verschoben worden wegen
des atomausstiegen sie wissen dass die
im laufenden Verfahren sind und sie
wissen auch dass ein Auto was nicht nach
zwei Jahren beim TÜV gewesen sondern
vielleicht nach zweieinhalb auch nicht
automatisch auseinander fällt wir wissen
nicht was da passiert ist ja keine Satz
was hätten sie denn eigentlich gewonnen
wenn wir darüber reden wenn diese drei
Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden aber
auf der Welt um uns herum die alte
älteren Meiler weiter offen und
zusätzlich immer neue meiner gebaut
werden was genau gewinnt eigentlich
Deutschland und dritter Punkt wird den
machen darf
wir schalten hier im Land ich weiß wie
viel Pools in diesem Land werden mit Gas
beheizt 20.000 vielleicht bundesweit die
werden abgeschaltet weil es offenbar ein
Problem mit der Gasversorgung gibt ich
habe immer gehört dass es knapp Gast
wird aber zur Stromproduktion auch
benutzt ganz entscheidend also wenn wir
da die Kernkraftwerke rausnehmen dann
müssten wir entweder zusätzlich diese
Lücke von rund 7 bis 8 Prozent die
Kernkraftwerke zur Stromproduktion
beitragen mit Gas auffüllen kann man
machen haben wir gerade wenig oder mit
Kohle und unser Eindruck war doch bisher
glaube ich der Hand da liege ich richtig
das genau die Kohle das Problem ist
deswegen wird ja zum Beispiel der
Kohleausstieg noch mal vorgezogen auf
2030 weil ganz ganz viel CO2 Luft geht
deswegen die Argumente die kommen die
sind so unterschiedlich aber sie sind
alle bemüht aber immer dieses Argument
entweder fossile oder Atomen
wir müssen von beiden loskommen
aber nein wir
aufgebrochen das stimmt überhaupt nicht
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung ist
eindeutig für längere Laufzeiten eine
ganz kurz und die Frage muss erlaubt
sein wenn Sie das sagen wir müssen auf
erneuerbare Energien setzen sagen Sie
doch mal wie das im Winter funktionieren
soll in diesem Winter und im nächsten wo
sehen Sie denn die Mehrheit für
Laufzeiten wenn wir gerade eine große
Wahl hatten Niedersachsen wo es um das
AKW Emsland geht und alle politische
Parteien
und ganz klar die Parteien die für den
Atomausstieg zum Jahresende waren
gewonnen haben und die Parteien die
gesagt haben wir müssen und das ist das
wichtigste Thema für uns die
Atomkraftwerke weiter betreiben
eine Partei die übrigens gar nicht für
Klimaschutz ist die nicht mehr das
Pariser Klimaabkommen anerkennt ist die
AFD und meines Wissens nach hat die
Niedersachsen nicht ganz schlecht
abgeschnitten bei der Wahl ja jetzt muss
man natürlich gucken dass es
verschiedene Ursachen hat
Totschlagargument dass alle Bürger in
Niedersachsen nur das wollen sie meinen
also die Erfolge nein aber ich sehe ich
ich sehe einfach dass wir Niedersachsen
gerade eine Wahl hatten die zum Großteil
auch um das Atomthema ging wo eine ganz
andere Entscheidung getroffen wird und
jetzt wird auf Bundesebene gesagt ihr
wollt nicht das Emsland weiterläuft eure
Regierung will nicht dass Emsland
weiterläuft trotzdem machen wir das und
das das Perfide an der ganzen Sache
übertragen
über ein einzelnes Atomkraftwerk und ich
glaube auch nicht dass die Anti
akw-bewegung sich einen Gefallen tut
jetzt mit so einem bunten Strauß an
Argumenten zu kommen
ihr Sicherheits ihre Sicherheitsbedenken
die sie jetzt geäußert haben die sind ja
für eine sehr spezifische Situation und
vor der Klammer steht ja sowieso
Atomkraftwerke laufen nur weiter solange
sie von den Aufsichtsbehörden auch
genehmigt werden wenn das nicht der Fall
ist wenn sie natürlich abgeschaltet es
aber schön nein das das soll hoffentlich
keine politische Entscheidung sein ja
aber Sie können ja politisch vereinbaren
wenn diese Bedingung erfüllt ist dann
dass wir sie weiterlaufen genauso können
Sie sagen wenn ihr kein Personal mehr
habt müssen wir natürlich die
Atomkraftwerke schließen logisch aber
wenn ihr Personal habt dann lassen wir
sie weiterlaufen es wird aber ein
Argument nach dem anderen nicht
genehmigungsfähig jetzt kommt in
Niedersachsen Wahl und so weiter das
macht die gesamte Position meines
Erachtens argumentativ immer schwächer
weil sie so situativ mit Einzelaspekten
kommt es gibt wenn Sie grundsätzlich
weiterhin sagen wir wollen kein
Atomkraft und dabei bleibt es nach ihrer
Ansicht dann würde ich das ja noch
nachvollziehen können aber dieses
sozusagen unterfüttern mit lauter
Argumenten die eigentlich nichts tragen
denn wir reden ja hier genau genommen
nicht über die Frage ob jetzt noch mal
ein einzelnes Atomkraftwerk dreieinhalb
Monate länger laufen soll oder ob die
anderen jetzt statt in diesem
streckt ja genau oder in die Notreserve
gehen das sind ja wirklich gegeben die
Herausforderung von die wir jetzt stehen
und zwar nicht nur im nächsten Winter
sondern für die nächsten 10 bis 15 Jahre
wirkliche petite testen das heißt du
musst jetzt ja grundsätzlich darüber
nachdenken wollen wir weiterhin diese
Technologie setzen ja oder nein aber da
muss man doch jetzt einfach sagen wir
haben doch die Situation dass wir in den
nächsten Monaten das sagt der Stress das
ganz klar im Worst Case-Szenario die die
Flüsse sind haben wir nicht genug Wasser
frankreich hat kein Atomkraftwerke
laufen Polen liefert nicht und kein Gas
dann haben wir drei bis zwölf Stunden im
Februar keinen Strom das ist das Worst
Case Szenario die großen alu-hütten
müssen drei bis zwölf Stunden
runtergefahren werden die Lösung ist wir
lassen Atomkraftwerke vier Monate weiter
laufen dadurch reduziert sich diese Zeit
auf null bis eine Stunde darüber reden
wir und deswegen wird ab November das
Atomkraftwerk Isa 2 runtergefahren damit
es weniger Strom produziert und dafür
länger produziert keine
Ahnung
wenn Sie die Sicherheitsbedenken hätten
dann müssten sie doch auch sagen es gibt
auch keine Verlängerung um drei Monate
dann werden die jetzt sofort abgeschafft
genau das habe ich das wollen sie doch
ja
ich muss auch sagen das ist ja
die Entscheidung des
Verwaltungsgerichtshofs in Mannheim der
am 14 Dezember darüber entscheidet
weiter betrieben werden kann oder nicht
einmal zu dieser Entscheidung die kommen
wir einmal zu dieser Entscheidung die
jetzt schon ganz oft angesprochen wurde
denn es wurde ja das erste Mal seit
Adenauer die Richtlinienkompetenz davon
Gebrauch gemacht und da ist ja auch von
Herr Scholz hat das denn nicht
vielleicht die prekäre Lage einfach in
der man sich auch befindet gezeigt wenn
man diese Entscheidung macht ist doch
alles politische Symbolik sie haben es
ja gerade gesagt ob die jetzt vier
Monate weiterlaufen oder nicht ändert
nichts an der Problematik das löst kein
Problem es ist politisches ja auf dem
Preis aber auch das was niemand
behauptet niemand sagt wenn wir
Atomkraftwerke da weiter laufen lassen
haben wir unser Energieproblem gelöst
das sagt keiner ich kenne jeweils
niemanden der das ernsthaft behaupten
würde sondern was gesagt wird ist es ist
ein Baustein in unserer zukünftigen
Energiestrategie und die müssen wir
ändern weil die die wir bislang gefahren
haben sich so nicht mehr realisieren
also auch unfair zu unterstellen
diejenigen die bereit sind weiter auf
die Atomkraft zu setzen würden damit
suggerieren dann werden unsere sonstigen
Probleme auch alle gelöst das sind sie
natürlich nicht ihr eigenes Instituts
nennt doch Atomenergie eine
konfliktreiche riskante und mit unserem
Energiesystem nicht kompatible
Energieform also langfristig ist das
falsch verstanden ja aber lang ich gehe
auf die Website langfristig ist
Atomenergie
Deutschland an als einziges Land mit
Österreich diese noch radikaler diesen
Sonderweg geht hat der Rest der Welt
sind die einfach vernagelt haben die
nicht begriffen aus ihrer Sicht wie
riskantes ist oder warum machen alle
anderen das inklusive Finnland und den
Grünen die dort neue Atomkraftwerke
bauen also korrigieren Sie mich wenn ich
falsch liege die 85% der Staaten der
Welt haben keine Atomenergie und das hat
einen guten Grund denn die Atomenergie
existiert praktisch nur in den Ländern
mit Atomwaffen und deren Verbündeten
weil Atomwaffen oder Atomen von Anbeginn
des Atomzeitalters miteinander verknüpft
ist unsere angstkultur daher kommt die
Angst vor der atomkosenindustrie aber
die großen
dass es genau aus dieser Angst
entstanden und das wissen wir ja auch
und die sind ja auch für den Wohlstand
erstmal für ihre Bevölkerung aber auch
für Teil des Wohlstands auf der Welt
verantwortlich setzen alle auf
atomenergien selbst Japan fängt wieder
an über den Neubau nachzudenken mich
würde trotzdem eins interessanter
wundert mich auch ihre Argumentation hat
mich wundert sie eigentlich nicht wie
kann es eigentlich sein dass sie sagen
weil in Frankreich die Kernkraftwerke
nicht funktionieren was sie doch wollen
ist doch nichts anderes als hier drei
abzuschalten in der Hoffnung dass in
Frankreich die älteren Dinger alle
wieder laufen das aber natürlich anders
geht's doch gar nicht Frankreich die
Atomkraftwerke angearbeitet werden viel
schwieriger und wie erklären sie sich
eigentlich dass in Frankreich der
CO2-Ausstoß pro Kopf halb so hoch ist
wie in Deutschland weil die weniger
Kohlekraftwerke haben richtig und was
haben sie Atomkraftwerk und erzählen Sie
mir den dritten Punkt noch mal wie
kommen wir in diesem und im nächsten
Winter ohne Kohlekraft und ohne
Kernkraft durch den Winter was
Frankreich in 20 Jahren macht wir reden
doch
wir reden jetzt mal über ein Problem was
jetzt zu lösen ist und wir können uns
ganz viel vor wir liefern nach
Frankreich Strom nicht Frankreich
aber reden wir doch bitte jetzt mal und
dann werde ich wenn ich es toll wenn Sie
die Frage beantworten könnten weil die
ist konkret was machen wir mit der Lücke
die wir dann hätten in einer Zeit in der
die Sonne relativ kurz scheint und
möglicherweise Wind auch nicht weht wie
füllen wir die Lücke auf die wenn wir
die Atomkraft rausnehmen dann gedeckt
werden haben sie den Stresstest gelesen
es geht nicht um die Antwort wo der Wind
nicht weht es geht um Zeiten wo der Wind
zu viel weht wir haben ja ein
Überangebot an Strom im Netz das ist das
Problem es gibt die dunkelblau das
wissen Sie auch wissen Sie ganz genau
sie kennen das doch alles aber Verhalten
sie doch die Zuschauer nicht für blöd
sagen Sie doch mal wie das Problem
gelöst habe ich gerade gesagt
abschalten für 12 Stunden
ihre Praxis oder was man sie auf
für ein paar Stunden groß Verbraucher
also Industrieunternehmen ja aber wie
stellen sich das vor die meisten
Menschen
wie stelle ich mir das vor es ist ein
Produktion die Aluminium produziert die
muss nicht die ganze Nacht produzieren
da kann man einen Deal machen und das
ist ja Usus das wird tagtäglich in
unsere Energie System gemacht ja das
heißt es muss nicht immer nur mehr mehr
aber genau diesen Dielen Strom Kunden
bezahlen weil diejenigen denen jetzt der
Strom abgeschaltet wird die werden
natürlich
entscheideanlage betreibt er ein
Windkraftwerk betreibt kennt das wenn es
ein Problem im Netz gibt dann wird man
abgeschaltet aber das heißt sie würden
für das Gemeinwohl die Frage fand ich
gerade gar nicht so wird sie würden für
ein gemeinsam wohl auch ihre Praxis dann
ein paar Stunden am Tag schließen weil
das Industrieunternehmen würden sie
machen fürs Gemeinwohl glaube wir müssen
alle diesen Winter und das sehe ich in
den Schulen das sehe ich in den
Ministerien das sehe ich auch in den
Arztpraxen und Krankenhäusern Energie
sparen das ist doch völlig völlig klar
was ich sagen will ist die Netzbetreiber
haben Pläne und Strategien wie Sie mit
dieser Situation umgehen die Klagen
nicht die sagen nicht machen keine Angst
vor Blackout weil die wissen wir kommen
damit klar und das Hauptproblem noch
einmal ist eine Überproduktion von Strom
in Norddeutschland bei gleichzeitig
hoher
Stromnutzung in Süddeutschland und an
beiden kann man sehen wissen gerade
schon was zum Beispiel bei E.ON oder
auch anderen los ist als die haben extra
psychologisch schon angestellt weil die
Verkäufer gar nicht mehr wissen wie sie
damit zurechtkommen wollen dass
Unternehmer mit selbstmorddrohen den sie
sagen ich weiß nicht ob ihr nächstes Gas
geben können ist nicht so als würden das
jetzt alle annehmen und sagen ist eine
großartige Lage aber diesen Strom dieses
strompreisproblem den lösen wir nicht
indem wir die atomkreis Problem das ist
ein Problem
und ich meine das ist ein Problem über
die zweitgrößte Industrienation der Welt
danke und die können sie eben
energiepolitisch nicht so steuern wie
ein Entwicklungsland wo sie sagen ja
also ob sie Strom bekommen oder nicht
das glauben steht in den Sternen so geht
es eben nicht also dann ist das eine
enorme standortbelastung wenn sie sagen
die ganzen Spitzen die wir dann ab bzw
die Täler die wir dann abfedern müssen
das machen wir über Abschaltung der
Industrie das Reden von 3 bis 12 Stunden
im Jahr wir reden von drei bis zwölf
Stunden an ein zwei Tagen im Februar
laut
Technologien
wir haben keinen Strom mehr Problem wir
haben ein netzstabilitätsproblem was ist
zu lösen und den Preisproblem haben wir
auf dem Kunden
bei dem Thema kommen wir nicht mehr auf
allen grünen Zweig das wollen wir auch
gar nicht bei feneracht streiten wir
gerne mal aber jetzt kommen wir zum
Thema von Herr Hank und ich hoffe die
anderen am Tisch verzeihen es mir ich
freue mich schon den ganzen Tag auf ihr
Thema ich glaube nämlich ich werde jetzt
gleich sehr viel lernen
also ich rede darüber was vor 50 Jahren
in Deutschland gewesen ist und da hatten
wir zum ersten Mal auch eine große
Energiekrise es war ein Schock die
Älteren werden sich noch erinnern man
erinnert sich vor allem an das Symbol
autofreie Sonntage das war so ein
bisschen Volksfest artig man konnte da
mit dem Kinderwagen und mit dem Fahrrad
auf der Autobahn spielen aber dahinter
verbirgt sich etwas sehr dramatisches
die Nachkriegszeit waren die goldenen
Jahre das Wachstums der
Vollbeschäftigung und offenkundig so
hatte man das Gefühl der unendlichen
Energie die uns immer zur Verfügung
scheint und dann kamen einige Dinge
gleichzeitig zusammen nämlich die OPEC
reduziert die Fördermengen zweitens es
gab ein Krieg in Israel Israel ist bis
heute ein politisch hochriskant das
Gebiet aber damals gab es den jungen
kippurkrieg und dass er zusätzlich dazu
geführt dass der Ölpreis nach oben
gegangen ist und zum in Deutschland
hatte man zum ersten Mal wieder in der
Nachkriegszeit man erinnerte sich an die
Zeiten der Vorkriegszeit hatte man eine
Inflation und ähnlich wie jetzt also ich
habe alles erwähnt Energiepreise
Lebensmittelpreisen Krieg und Angst vor
Krieg in der Welt und Angst man kann
sich sein Leben nicht mehr finanzieren
ähnlich war die Ausgangssituation aber
die Lösung damals war eine klügere als
es jetzt ist denn die Notenbank die ist
damals Bundesbank die den Zins bestimmen
konnte hat viel viel schneller und viel
viel beherzter eingegriffen nämlich den
Zins nach oben gesetzt das ist die erste
der erste Unterschied weil die EZB lange
lange gezögert hat mit Angst die muss ja
auf alle europäischen Länder Rücksicht
nehmen mit Angst auf die Südstaaten
hatte sie Angst zu schnell die Zinsen zu
erhöhen dann können die ihren
Staatshaushalt nicht mehr finanzieren
das zweite war aus meiner Sicht noch
entscheidender die fiskalpol also das
was der Staat Geld ausgibt ging damals
im Tandem mit der Geldpolitik also es
wurde nicht wie bei uns jetzt rein
gebuttert
Gaspreis also an den Preisen
herumgefummelt alle die irgendwann
schreien wurden entschädigt all das war
damals nicht so nur die Armen die
wirklich Bedürftigen bekamen einmalig
300 Mark mehr wurde fiskalpolitisch
nicht getan und das führte dazu dass
anders auch in als in Amerika
Deutschland das erste Land oder eines
der ersten Länder gewesen ist die die
Inflation wieder in Griff bekommen haben
wir sind jetzt bei 10% in Deutschland
ist es nie über 8% gewesen das heißt die
Zäsur und das sagen alle
Wirtschaftshistoriker die epochenwände
und zeitenwände die die Nachkriegszeit
zweiteilt ist in Deutschland vor 50
Jahren eindeutig besser gehandelt worden
als jetzt das macht einem ein bisschen
Sorge kläre dich die Frage direkt Herr
Hand kann die Politik es denn heute auch
noch so gut händeln wie damals oder sind
eben schon selbst die EZB angesprochen
haben die einfach weniger Power Power
haben die schon aber die EZB das hängt
mit einem Konstruktionsfehler der
Europäischen
Währungsunion insgesamt zusammen hat
unterschiedliche
Länder auf die sie schaut und versucht
ein Kompromiss daraus zu machen dann
kann man sagen da sieht man man hätte
sich nie darauf einlassen sollen oder
gleich vereinigten wird es gibt ja Leute
die das wollen ich will das nicht aber
gleich Vereinigte Staaten von Europa
Gründen aber diese Zwischenzustand der
Macht in macht was die Geldpolitik
betrifft ein großes Problem in Amerika
hat die Zentralbank viel viel schneller
eingegriffen aber hier war lange lange
eine Unsicherheiten als sie einen
angefangen haben haben sie zu wenig die
Zinsen erhöht noch gravierende auch hier
ist und da ist aus meiner Sicht Corona
Schuld die Vorstellung immer wenn es
eine Verschlechterung der
Lebenssituation gibt dann muss der Staat
das Ausgleichen der Staat muss dann
helfen und das hat unterschiedliche aber
nur schlechte Konsequenzen nämlich die
Vorstellung der Bürger ist erst einmal
für sich selber verantwortlich und ich
glaube alle die hier am Tisch sitzen die
kommen damit hin auch ohne dass sie
kompensiert werden müssen vom Staat aber
diese Einstellung wandelt sich sehr und
das hat nicht nur für die Mentalitäten
und für eben der Staat muss helfen
Auswirkungen sondern es hat eben auch
fiskalpolitische Auswirkungen dass dann
jetzt die Inflation sogar durch die
Fiskalpolitik noch hochgehen könnte in
dem Maße in dem dann auch die
Staatsverschuldung hochgeht jan ist da
ist das der richtige Ansatz zu sagen
dass die Anspruchshaltung der Staat
regelt schon der Staat richtet schon das
stimmt ja schon seit der corona-pandiert
man späte man merkt auch schuld ist ich
glaube da ist ganz ganz viel dran wenn
ich das so bescheiden sagen darf an dem
was reiner Hand gesagt hat und was mir
auffällt ist das klingt ja auch an bei
dem was Sie gesagt haben ist das der
Staat natürlich versucht über
preissetzungen immer stärker auch in
Mechanismen einzugreifen also diese
diese Hilfe wir wissen das Preise extrem
wichtig sind um Knappheiten klingt ja so
technisch aber um Knappheiten eigentlich
darzustellen und dann etwas knapp ist
dann überlegen sich die Menschen und
auch die Firmen ganz häufig was kann ich
tun um um kreativ und werden kreativ
ganz genauso aber wissen auch dass
Preise für Politiker zum Teil ganz ganz
also furchterregend sind beim Thema
mieten beispielsweise bei Preise auch
Versagen dokumentieren können beim Thema
mieten wissen wir das und was hat der
rot-rot-grüne Senat in Berlin gemacht
als die Mieten explodiert sind hat nicht
gesagt oh wir müssen mehr bauen und
vielleicht eine andere Wohnungspolitik
machen nein hat einfach ein mietendeckel
eingezogen und einen Preis begrenzt und
in der Hoffnung dann dass das Problem
damit gelöst ist nein das Problem ist
natürlich nicht gelöst deswegen ist der
Preis so wichtig und was hier gesagt
wird und was reine Hand gerade sagt oder
das hier gemacht wird und reiner Hand ja
gerade sagt ist dass man auch jetzt
wieder versucht Preise zuzukleistern zu
begrenzen zu deckeln und damit die
Situation falsch handelt im Vergleich
sogar Fehlanreize setzt weil wenn man
das Gefühl hat bei 12 Cent ist jetzt
Lust den Rest übernimmt der Staat das
sehe ich ja nicht dass ich das über
Schulden oder über meine Steuern
finanziere dann denkt man ja dann ist es
gar nicht so schlimm dann kann ich ja
weiter feuern und den Pool dann doch
weiter ran lassen also es hat nur nur
negative Auswirkungen
Reize die gesetzt werden ich habe eine
Frage eine Verständnisfrage sie sagten
also die Inflation dieser über 10% ist
ja ein Großteil zurückzuführen auf die
die aktuelle Gaskrise Energiepreise
wären wir in Deutschland jetzt besser
aufgestellt wenn wir vor 10 15 Jahren
konsequenter von den fossilen
Brennstoffen weggekommen zu erneuerbaren
Energien hingekommen wären würde dann
diese Krise weniger betreffen wie andere
Länder gerade ich denke ja also Länder
die stärker mit heimischer Energie es
machen auch die Schweiz zum Beispiel
weil sie sehr viel Wasser hat hat
bislang eine deutlich geringere
Inflation aber wir haben uns ja doppelt
belogen wir haben gesagt wir machen wir
steigen aus aus der aus dem Öl wir
steigen aus aus der Atomkraft haben wir
vorher darüber diskutiert und machen die
Transformation zu den erneuerbaren das
ja wir haben es nicht getan aber wir
haben den Leuten auch nicht gesagt dass
die Brücke dazwischen ausschließlich
billiges russisches Gas ist das ist die
Lebenslüge auch der Grünen sagen wir
aller Parteien die regiert haben in den
letzten Jahren
wie würden sie es einschätzen das ist
jetzt nicht nur ein Problem der
aktuellen Regierung das haben wir auch
in den vorangegangenen Regierungen
gesehen dass man immer dann wenn es
Konflikte gab sie mit Staatsgeld
zugeschüttet hat und wir haben eben eine
Politik gemacht die genau das nicht
unterstützt hat was sie sagen nämlich an
die für die Zukunft vorzusorgen stärker
zu investieren sondern wir haben
Wesentlichen die Ansprüche an den
Sozialstaat weiter ausgebaut den wir
dann in die Rentenpolitik denken da gab
es noch einen Herrn Müntefering ist aber
auch schon fast 20 Jahre her der erkannt
hat man muss das Problem an der Wurzel
packen und hatte durchgesetzt Rente mit
67 seitdem gab es nur noch Veränderungen
im Rentensystem die die Ansprüche an das
Rentensystem erhöht haben also wo gerade
die konstruktiven Bereiche gestärkt
worden sind das deutet nicht darauf hin
weil man davon ausgehen kann dass sich
die Politiker sehr stark nach Umfragen
orientiert haben dass das populär
gewesen wäre zu sagen wir müssen leider
eure konsumansprüche jetzt etwas
einbremsen weil wir brauchen die Mittel
für die zusätzlichen Ausbau
beispielsweise der
alternativen Energien dafür gab es
offensichtlich keine Mehrheiten und das
wird auch jetzt schwierig werden denn
die Verteilungskonflikte werden in
diesem Jahrzehnt ohnehin zu nehmen durch
die Demografie bekommen wir noch
zusätzliche Unwucht in den sozialen
Sicherungssystemen die Wachstumskräfte
werden schwächer und die Energiewende
jetzt ganz unabhängig davon dass wir
jetzt noch diese Krise haben am
aktuellen Rand wäre ohnehin eher ein
wachstumsbelastender Faktor gewesen denn
wir bauen damit ja unseren
Kapitalstock im Wesentlichen um und
nicht auf also das was wir normalerweise
mit Investitionen verbinden mehr
Produktionsmöglichkeiten in der Zukunft
das tritt jetzt dadurch erstmal nicht
ein sondern wir ersetzen bestimmte
Energieform die wir nicht mehr wollen
durch jetzt erneuerbare aber wir
produzieren am Ende noch genauso viel
das heißt keine zusätzlichen Konsumgüter
die dann auch zur Verteilung anstehen
würden das heißt das werden noch sehr
schwierige Jahre
der Krieg
ja sozusagen der verschärft jetzt den
Anpassungsdruck unter dem wir stehen und
er zeigt symptomatisch worauf sich die
Politik dann verständigen kann nämlich
auf zusätzliche Schulden und das finde
ich am
spektakulärsten bei der bei der äußeren
Sicherheit also da gibt es glaube ich
sehr wenig dezents unter einem ganz
weiten Spektrum von Ökonomen bis weit in
das auch ganz
liberale Spektrum hinein dass die
Verteidigung natürlich eine
Staatsaufgabe ist und die Ausgaben dafür
gehören in der in den staatlichen
Haushalt und dass wir es nicht geschafft
haben den Verteidigungshaushalt
innerhalb des regulären Budgets genau
aufwachsen zu lassen das zeigt ja nur
dass man eben gerade nicht die Kraft hat
die politische Kraft hat dann an anderer
Stelle im Budget auch mal etwas
zurückzunehmen sondern man weicht immer
aus in zusätzliche Schulden und das wird
in diesem Jahrzehnt und im
darauffolgenden Jahrzehnt immer
schwieriger werden jan ist das
Augenwischerei für den Steuerzahler wenn
man immer Sondervermögen ausruft
natürlich ist es das und wir waren ja
auf muss man ja sagen brachial geradezu
aus einem
ideologischen pazifistischen Traum und
stellen fest so schöne Radwege ist auch
gibt in Deutschland und so wunderbar
sich die Windräder auch drehen wir uns
in dem Land das wirklich wunderbar und
sehr hübsch ist wir können diese
Schönheit selbst gar nicht er
verteidigen gegen einen Aggressor Putin
wenn er bei uns vor der Tür stehen würde
dann müssten wir sagen ja tut uns leid
aber die schönen Radwege und das ganze
schöne Land was wir hier aufgebaut haben
das können wir gar nicht verteidigen
weil wir das Geld zu großen Teil ist
falsch gesagt überhaupt nicht aber
teilweise einfach priorisiert oder
falsch priorisiert haben und falsch
eingesetzt haben und ich glaube das ist
eine Erkenntnis die wir haben jetzt aus
dem angriffstieg den Wladimir Putin
führt dass doch jedem klar sein muss und
man sieht sie ja bei den Grünen
mittlerweile auch dass das was wir hier
im Land aufbauen immer auch selbst
verteidigt werden muss und man sich
nicht immer auf Amerika da auch
verlassen sollte sondern das Geld expliz
ich dann auch für Rüstung und für die
Verteidigung die zweite Lüge eben die
eine ist wir haben so getan als würde
das billige russische Gas immer fließen
und haben uns extrem abhängig gemacht
von einem schurtenstart und wir haben
uns auf der anderen Seite kein
schurkenstart aber was die Sicherheit
betrifft abhängig gemacht von Amerika
nach dem Motto werden die dafür schon
sorgen wir sind ja Pazifisten so kann
sich Pazifismus und zugleich auch
klima-moralismus wunderbar wohlfühlen
weil der Rest der Welt dafür zustehen
und dann und was wir so produzieren
unsere Ingenieure und unsere Manager und
die Arbeiter vor allem in Stuttgart das
wird in China gekauft also dass der Rest
der Welt sagt gut dass euch diese drei
Lügen jetzt ein bisschen ja um die Ohren
oder auf die Füße fallen das kann man
denen nicht verarschen und die Frage ist
tatsächlich wie gehen wir mit dieser
Erfahrung jetzt um und noch einmal auf
72 zu sprechen zu kommen Wachstum kommt
vor allem durch Innovation und
Kreativität und 72 war ein großer
kreativitäts- und Wachstumsschub nämlich
dann wenn man sieht
das die Energie ist nicht immer billig
dann effizienter zu produzieren also
dass wir mit einem mittlerweile in
Faschist gekommen aber mit einer
Tankfüllung von Ravenna nach Frankfurt
fahren können ist eine Folge eine
technologische Folge der
72/72er Aufruf ist für mehr Kreativität
auf der einen Seite des Transformation
in die Erneuerbaren aber parallel dazu
würde ich weiter auch die Kreativität
beim Verbrenner laufen lassen und nicht
das hat man 72 auch nicht gemacht weil
keine Verbote ausgesprochen sondern der
Markt hat quasi diese Kreativität
entwickelt nicht weil der Markt einfach
irgendwie was was mysteriöses tolles ist
sondern aus der Not und dem Druck heraus
wir möchten nicht ein zweites Mal in
diese Bredouille kommen wir bleiben
einmal noch bei dem Krieg Herr Rosen da
die Frage schaffen wir bei dem Thema
Konsens am Tisch dass sie immer ganz
nett sind sie denn auch der Meinung dass
wir vielleicht militärisch uns nicht
genug abgesichert haben
wir sind ja als Deutschland in ein
Militärbündnis und in einen in die
Europäische Union integriert deswegen
ist es ja nicht so dass wir als
Deutschland sozusagen nur für uns
zuständig sind deswegen gibt es ja
Organisationen wie die NATO ich also man
kann jetzt über Militärpolitik lang und
breit reden das springt doch jetzt in
Rahmen sprengen ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass wir schauen dass die
Situation wie sie jetzt in Osteuropa in
der Ukraine ist nicht nur durch einen
Mann im Kreml entstanden ist sondern
durch eine leider fehlgeleitete
Außenpolitik vieler Seiten seit Ende des
Kalten Krieges seit den 90er Jahren
haben wir es nicht geschafft in Europa
eine gemeinsame Sicherheitsarchitektur
mit Russland zum aufzubauen und dann
müssen sich ganz viele Leute auf die
eigene Nase schauen und man kann nicht
sagen das ist wlady Martins schuld da
haben auch wir im Westen
an dem Krieg ja aber an der Situation
die die zu diesem Krieg geführt hat da
haben wir auch versagt als Westen eine
Sicherheitsarchitektur zu schaffen die
so etwas verhindern kann wir haben auch
leider muss man sagen hat die USA ganz
wichtige rüstungsabkommen
rüstungsbegrenzungsabkommen aufgekündigt
völlig ohne Not
sodass wir jetzt in der Situation sind
wo die Bedrohung durch Atomwaffen
beispielsweise durch russischer
Atomwaffen viel größer ist als zu den
schlimmsten Zeiten des Kalten Krieges
und das ist eine Situation
die wir haben passieren lassen und wo
wir uns sehr gut die Lektion angucken
müssen für die Zeit nach Wladimir Putin
also die Aussage da gab es leider Putin
glaube ich ist außer Frage steht außer
Frage wer der Aggressor in diesem Spiel
ist und Fehler sind immer auf allen
Seiten möglicherweise gemacht worden
aber das rechtfertigt in keinster Weise
so ein Krieg zu führen bei der erlaubt
diese NATO weil er aus der eigenen Logik
kommt wäre ein militärisches
angriffsbündnis das Gegenteil ist der
Fall und das ist das was glaube ich in
der russischen Seele ganz tief drin ist
da wird immer geguckt man hat
automatisch das Gefühl man fühlt sich
permanent bedroht weil man selbst
dauernd andere Länder bedroht und das
ist das was wir hier wirklich jetzt paar
excellence erleben deswegen glaube ich
wie konnten wir denn Russen das verkauft
wir bleiben bei dem konsentiert der der
wahre Aggressor ist weil da sind sich
wirklich alle am Tisch einig und wir
gehen eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung bis
gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter brauchen
und ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfe
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi
aber niemand von dem politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken ich habe meinen
Beifall in meine lache immer bekommen
wer kümmert sich darum niemand dit ist
bald ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal
auch darüber sprechen das ist einfach
nicht fair ist und nicht richtig durch
die Aufgabe von Journalismus einfach die
die Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück wollen keine Zeit
verlieren und machen direkt weiter mit
ihrem Thema
mit dem russischen Überfall auf die
Ukraine ist der wichtigste Brücken
Energieträger für die deutsche
Energiewende weggefallen und es fehlt
uns jetzt eine neue Strategie Strategie
bedeutet nicht nur zu sagen wo man in 20
Jahren sein will sondern auch wie man
dort hinkommt das hat die
Bundesregierung bislang immer noch nicht
beantwortet stattdessen hangelt Sie sich
von einem Entlastungspaket zum nächsten
typischerweise zu breit angelegt klar
ist nur die Energiepreise werden kaum
noch auf das vor krisen-niveau
zurückfallen damit es aber auch unklar
welche Unternehmen in Deutschland noch
eine Zukunft haben und das Risiko ist
groß dass man mit all diesen
überbrückungsprogrammen Brücken ins
Nichts baut weil man gar nicht weiß wo
das andere
Ufer liegt Energie ist knapp und wir
müssen jetzt Energie sparen und es geht
jetzt um die intelligentesten Umgang wie
wir das hinbekommen nun dann müssen wir
die Welt nicht neu erfinden der beste
Mechanismus um mit Knappheiten
klarzukommen sind Märkte und
Preissignale die können uns am ehesten
sagen wo wir jetzt insbesondere auf Gas
verzichten müssen Preise sind eben nicht
nur Symptom des Problems sondern immer
auch schon Teil der Lösung das
Preissystem ist das Navigationssystem
der Wirtschaft
man würde beim Auto das Navi auch nicht
abschalten nur weil der Weg ruppiger
wird die Bundesregierung war auch
zunächst auf der richtigen Spur nämlich
mit der gasumlage zu versuchen diesen
Anstieg der Preise möglichst breit
wirken zu lassen so dass jeder es spürt
und nicht nur diejenigen die das Pech
hatten dass der Gasvertrag gerade
auslief oder der eigene Lieferant
insolvent gegangen ist davon ist sie
leider wieder abgerückt hat sich dann
zunehmend auf die Diskussion um eine
gaspreisbremse eingelassen und damit
versucht die Preissignale eher wieder
runter zu dimmen das ist aber der
falsche Weg wir haben einen hohen
Importanteil das bedeutet das bedarf
erheblicher Subventionen die
preiseingriff wirken viel zu sehr in der
Breite das erhöht die Inflationsgefahr
und da wir jetzt immer mehr nationale
Alleingänge in der EU in diese Richtung
erleben drohen wir sogar damit die
Weltmarktpreise für Gas hochzuhalten und
damit nicht die europäischen Verbraucher
zu entlasten sondern die
Lieferanten in Übersee zu füttern kurzum
die gasumlage war besser als ihr Ruf man
hätte sie noch verbessern können aber
sie war insgesamt der richtige Weg und
die gaspreisbremse hält nicht was sie
verspricht das heißt wir sollten wieder
auf einen Kurs zurückkehren wo wir viel
mehr mit den Marktkräften spielen als
permanent gegen sie hier natürlich
direkt die Frage an den bildpolitikchef
kann es denn überhaupt sein dass man
noch mal zurückkehrt zur Gas im Lager
nein ich glaube der Weg ist
ausgeschlossen also da gab es viel viel
Kritik und die gasumlage ist ja de facto
auch schon abgeschafft also das wird
nichts mehr werden am Ende sind wir bei
einem Punkt den wir gerade eben ja auch
schon Sprachen
mit der Hand hat das angesprochen und
sie jetzt gerade auch noch mal am Ende
die Frage wie hilft man denjenigen die
es am nötigsten haben in dieser Krise
eigentlich am stärksten ich weiß nicht
ob die gasumlage da das beste Mittel
gewesen wäre klar ist glaube ich dass es
darum geht vor allem jeden Haushalten
und auch dann jeden Firmen zu helfen die
am härtesten betroffen sind die sich das
am wenigsten leisten können die
möglicherweise auch vom Konkurs dann
stehen und viele andere Menschen können
das eher abschöpfen aus dem eigenen aus
eigenen Ersparnissen aus dem eigenen
Einkommen und müssen das auch tun in
klar ist auch der Staat und das sind am
Ende wir alle immer wir können das ja
nicht selbst alles bezahlen es können
viele für einige bezahlen aber nicht
alle für alle das wird nicht
funktionieren ich würde an einer Stelle
Ihnen widersprechen Herr kurz nämlich
was die Umlage betrifft da ging es ja
darum dass die großen Energiehändler
also wie Juniper war immer das Beispiel
jetzt hohe Einkaufspreise haben aber
langfristige Verträge mit den
Stadtwerken oder auch einzelnen
Großkunden und ins entsprechend die
höheren Preise nicht weitergeben kann
warum wird das über eine Umlage machen
sollen und nicht gleich in dem wir dann
den gefährdeten Unternehmen helfen in
dem was sie als hinterher auch passiert
ist und aus meiner Sicht zurecht und gut
passiert ist also diese Schleife die man
gedreht hat die dann dazu geführt hat
dass Trittbrettfahrer auftauchen die das
gar nicht nötig haben die hätte man
vermeiden können also ich würde sagen
sie müssen eigentlich ihr Argumenten
schärfen ohne dass ich dazu habe in ihre
Argumente zu schärfen aber zu sagen
direkt Hilfen jedes Mal direkt Hilfe was
die großen Energiehändler betrifft und
direkt Hilfe was die direkten ja was den
ärmeren Teil der Bevölkerung über der
hartz-iv-schwelle die ohnehin Wohngeld
und
die die Miete und die Energie bezahlt
bekommen auch hier direkt bezahlen dann
ist es kein Eingriff in den
Preismechanismus und erfüllt völlig das
Ziel dass sie sehr dankbar für die Frage
weil er genau auf den Punkt zielt an dem
die Debatte falsch abgebogen ist nämlich
der Eindruck ist entstanden wir hätten
diese gasumlage nur um die Unternehmen
zu retten darum ging es ja gar nicht das
war ein Nebeneffekt sondern es ging
darum die höheren Beschaffungspreise
also die höhere Knappheit die sich jetzt
an den Märkten gezeigt hat möglichst
auch bei den Preisen der Verbraucher
auch ankommen zu lassen dass also jemand
der das Glück hatte vielleicht noch
einen langlaufenden Vertrag zu sehr
günstigen Konditionen zu haben dass auch
der das Preissignal bekommt nein Gas ist
jetzt knapper geworden also bitte nicht
so viel gasverbrauchen wie in der
Vergangenheit das war die primäre
Zielrichtung also hier die
preisüberwälzung zu beschleunigen das
ist nicht optimal ausgestaltet worden
durch mit diesen 2,4 Cent für jeden das
hätte man noch ein bisschen besser
machen können aber die Richtung war
schon genau die die man hätte gehen
können und das ist kein Eingriff in dem
Sinne in das
Preissystem sondern man hätte hier die
die Arbeit der Preise gelockert und
daran hätte man Zwischenfrage stellen
wenn man das zur Preise sind ja
unfassbar viele Begriffe ich frage mich
gerade wirklich ob die im Bundestag das
überhaupt alles verstehen es ist ja
hochkomplex und man hat ja das Gefühl
die verstehen es gar nicht wenn man auf
die Steigung Preise schaut das würde ich
jetzt so das glaube ich nicht sondern es
gibt genügend Überblick das ja also es
gibt ja auch ein also auch gerade den
Ministerien in den Fachabteilungen sehr
gute Leute das ist glaube ich kein
Erkenntnisproblem ist eine Frage ob man
es politisch tatsächlich mehrheitsfähig
machen kann daran ist man gescheitert
denn die Idee der gasumlage ist ja nicht
zufällig entstanden und natürlich das
ist jetzt kein Instrument um die
Bedürftigen zu entlasten sondern das
belastet natürlich erstmal das muss man
dann immer flankieren mit entsprechend
zum Beispiel energiepreisgeld war gar
keine so schlechte Idee dass man also
einen Betrag überweist und der wird dann
abgeschmolzen wir haben es mit der
Steuer gemacht ich kann mir das noch
aggressiver vorstellen dass man sagt
bist du mittleren Einkommen wird denn
dieser Transferbetrag abgeschmolzen
um auch hier dafür zu sorgen dass wir
nicht unnötig viel zusätzliche Kaufkraft
in den privaten sektorpumpen den das
aktuelle inflationsproblem ist leider
nicht nur ein Energiepreis Phänomen
sondern wir sehen auch dass die
heimischen Komponenten der Teuerung
bereits anziehen und zwar kräftig
anziehen viel stärker als es mit dem
stabilitätsziel der Geldpolitik
vereinbar ist und das ist eine ja auch
Nachfolge dessen was wir während der
corona-pandemie gemacht haben das wäre
also so oder so eingetreten dass jetzt
noch akzentuiert durch die Preise aber
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir hier die
Inflation nicht noch weiter anfeuern
denn das ist ja ein Bärendienst für
diejenigen die ganz unten in der
einkommens-haltung auch teurer und
deshalb müssen wir gerade dafür sorgen
dass wir die sozialen Hilfen so gut
fokussieren wie irgendwie möglich und
die Inflation beschäftigt ihr uns alle
und auch wir bleiben hier bei 8:15 Uhr
weiter bei dem Thema dran aber jetzt
kommen wir zur Schulbildung auch einen
nicht zu verachtendes Thema in diesem
Land mit Jan Schäfer ja sein harter wir
machen vom Thema Inflation und
Energiekrise hin zu einer anderen Krise
die mich aber wahnsinnig umtreibt es gab
zu Beginn der Woche eine wirklich
dramatische Studie die sich beschäftigt
mit den Mathe und Deutschkenntnissen der
Schülerinnen und Schüler in der vierten
Klasse in Deutschland da kam heraus dass
die Leistungen in den vergangenen fünf
Jahren deutlich nachgelassen haben immer
mehr Schüler haben Probleme die
Mindeststandards beim Rechnen und beim
Lesen in der vierten Klasse zu erfüllen
nicht nur Corona ist ausschlaggebend
gewesen sondern generell der Zustand
unseres nicht richtig guten Schulsystems
und das kann man natürlich auch
hochrechnen ökonome in dem Fall nicht
vom Institut für Weltwirtschaft in Kita
von ifo Institut aus München haben das
gemacht und haben festgestellt
schwächere Bildung lernverluste sorgen
dafür dass man über sein Leben ein
geringeres Erwerbseinkommen hat also
weniger verdient und natürlich das
Wirtschaftswachstum am Land auch viel
geringer ausfällt das sind alles keine
wirklich guten Nachrichten das ist
glaube ich ein Alarmsignal was
Wiedersehen das heißt wir müssen weg von
dem Experimentieren weg von solchen
ideologischen Dingen auch wie das
Schreiben nach Gehör sondern wieder hin
zu einem klassischen Schulbetrieb zu
einem leeren und einem Lernenden sonst
steht es um unser Land die Zukunft
dieses Landes nicht besonders gut Herr
Rosen sie jetzt Kinderarzt haben viel
Kontakt mit Kindern was ist da los
ich habe Kontakt im Kindern die meine
Praxis kommen da kriege ich natürlich
viel vom Bildungssystem mit ich habe
einen differenziertes Bild vom
Bildungssystem ich sehe die Probleme die
sie auch angesprochen haben bin da auch
größtenteils da core dass wir wirklich
ein großes Problem haben in Deutschland
was nicht nur auf die corona-pandemie
geschoben werden kann ganz klar es war
noch mal großes Problem in den letzten
Jahren aber das Problem hat ja vorher
schon angefangen ich sehe aber auch dass
das Schulsystem lernfähig ist dass wir
viele Leute viele Kinder mittlerweile in
diesem Schulsystem viel besser abholen
als das noch der Fall war als ich zum
Beispiel zur Schule gegangen bin wo es
damals es gab diese Einrichtung für
schwererziehbare Kinder es gab
einfach diesen Begriff das sind Kinder
die sind im Schulsystem Inklusion nicht
nur Inklusion sondern eine
differenziertere Betrachtung von Bedarf
und differenzierte Förderung früher war
das Kind schwer erziehbar heute guckt
man genauer hin mit
Fachlehrern mit förderlehrern die gucken
warum ist das kein schwer erziehbar hat
vielleicht ein Aufmerksamkeitsdefizit
Käse rechtschreibstörung hat es
vielleicht ein intelligenzmangel ist gar
nicht an der falschen an der richtigen
Schulform und diese Differenzierung
führt dazu dass viele Leute die damals
durch dieses Raster gefallen wären jetzt
viel besser anhand Ihrer individuellen
Möglichkeiten gefördert werden können
was nicht bedeutet dass das
Gesamtschulsystem dadurch massiv besser
geworden ist die Leistung ich glaube da
muss man nicht drüber reden sind
verbesserungswürdig aber das ist das mit
einem Paradoxon zu tun hier sitzen
Ökonom am Tisch deswegen Paradoxon 1 die
Leistungen der Schüler werden schlechter
Paradoxon 2 auch im internationalen
Vergleich übrigens das sehen wir ja das
geht eher wieder zurück nach dem ersten
Pisa-Schock wird wieder schlechter
paroxon 2 immer mehr Leute in
Deutschland machen Abitur und haben auch
eine einsform Komma also das klappt aus
meinem international werden wir maximal
gleich gut oder schlechter aber im
nationalen Vergleich immer mehr Einser
Abiturienten das heißt auch da lügen wir
uns eigentlich ordentlich was in die
Tasche Form von Inflationen
ich glaube ja ernster was vorlegen Lügen
ich glaube aber auch den Forschern am
Ifo-Institut die Sie gerade schon
zitiert haben die sagen wir setzen
falsche Prioritäten der tertiäre Sektor
und die Universitäten werden bei uns zu
sehr gepäppelt also während wir in der
frühkindlichen Bildung und in der
kita-phase zu wenig tun und das ist
nicht nur eine Frage des Geldes aber
eben auch das Geldes es ist aber auch
und da gibt es gute Vorbilder aus
Amerika Förderung von Kindern und Eltern
also gerade nicht separieren und dann
Eltern liegen kann das liegt also ganz
ganz eindeutig und da jetzt diese Studie
die ja Mathe und
schreitkenntnisse als nochmals
schlechter
herausbekommen hat hat jetzt zugleich
auch gesagt es liegt natürlich auch an
der Migration und das ist ja
andererseits toll dass wir Migranten
Kinder in das Schulsystem in die Bildung
integrieren und ihnen damit zukunfts-
eröffnet die sie nicht gehabt hätten
aber das würden wir besser hinbekommen
wenn wir hier noch stärker eine
verzahnte Förderung von Kindern und
Eltern geht es vor allem
Sprachkenntnisse aber es geht auch um
kulturelle Kenntnisse vermitteln würden
das ein schönes Schlusswort und Einigung
am Ende hier am Tisch Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend wenn Sie mögen dann
schalten sie doch morgen abend wieder
ein tschüss machen sie es gut
[Musik]